foreign
people it is May 30th 2023 I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Reuben report we are
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals did we skip our cold open today
we skipped our cold open I don't know
why there may have been some sort of
technical problem we will deal with it
later in our team meeting uh but we got
a big show for you uh remember guys we
are two days away from pride month and
by the end of pride month June which is
pride month by the end of pride month if
you and everyone
that you know is not trans you will be
sent to the gulag okay that's how it's
going to be if your penis is not a
vagina by the end of June that's that
we've got to take you out that's how
it's going to be in America and that's
sort of in a bizarre sense has a little
bit to do with what we are doing today
because uh the woke corporations are
completely out of control they ain't
gonna stop uh but we are hitting them
and it's kind of working so we're going
to be talking about the rise and fall of
woke capitalism here in America and how
the corporate media goes through hell
and back to defend these corporations
but alas people there are some people
fighting them you're fighting them the
people boycott and Bud Light are
fighting them the people boy cotton
Target are fighting them this guy Ron
DeSantis is fighting them and much more
and anyway I hope you had a great
Memorial Day Weekend took a little time
to remember the the people we lost who
uh fought for our freedom so we get to
do silly things like I do for a living
and uh we actually had our first uh one
little little side note we had our first
hospital adventure with the boys on
Thursday Night Luke was uh vomiting
pretty usually went a little pale took
him to the hospital he's okay
apparently it was some bad yogurt maybe
we're not even sure but he was totally
fine a little drama but it kind of puts
things in uh in perspective and uh oh
and uh speaking of uh Memorial Day which
obviously it was I wanted to ask the
guys because it's Tuesday today how many
people were shot in Chicago
that was a hell of a segue I don't know
how I did that Segway right there but I
wanted to ask the guys how many people
were shot in Chicago uh 53 people were
shot in Chicago and still as of right
now the NAACP has not given any travel
advisory to Illinois or the city of
Chicago very bizarre anyway as you can
see we're gonna be packing in a lot in
the show today let's talk about CB
Distillery and then we'll get to it guys
anyone who knows or thinks they won't
need emergency food isn't paying
attention every day the headlines get
worse and worse is the unthinkable next
it pays to prepare which is why I
recommend you stock up on emergency food
right away you never know when the next
shoe will drop and when it does
emergency food will be hard to find so
get yours now while it's on sale go to
mypatriotsupply.com and check out their
popular three-month emergency food kit
right now you'll save 200 per kit each
kit gives you a wide variety of
delicious breakfasts lunches dinners
drinks and snacks providing over 2 2000
calories a day for Optimum strength and
energy act now and claim your 200
savings per kit you'll sleep better
knowing your family won't suffer if the
worst ever happens go to
mypatriotsupply.com and you'll enjoy
free shipping as well my Patriot
supply.com and now back to me okay so
let's just get right into it the the
under theme meaning the major theme
lately has been politics DeSantis Trump
all that stuff but the sort of secondary
theme right beneath that lately has been
that there has been some serious
pushback against World corporations
which you have to love because it shows
that you the person with the pocket the
guy who goes out and makes choices in
what you buy and what you give your
attention to and your hard-earned
dollars and all of those things you have
a little bit of capacity to change the
system you guys know Kevin O'Leary Kevin
O'Leary of course investor from Shark
Tank we've played a couple clips of him
uh over the years uh he was given I
believe this is from CNBC if I'm not
mistaken anyway yeah CNBC am I right I'm
sorry this is on Fox Business uh talking
about how the corporations like
Anheuser-Busch which of course owns Bud
Light and the other ones that are going
woke they are paying a price and it is
good that they are
well Bud Light has become the poster boy
for brand mismanagement from multiple
perspectives so let me let me lay it out
for you because these the discussions
that have Arisen and the narrative
that's risen around Bud Light is
probably a good lesson for every CEO in
every sector of the economy number one
it highlights the power of social media
this this issue went viral in 48 hours
yeah and most often when an issue goes
viral like that it burns out in another
48 hours but that's not what happened
here the story and narrative change to
sales and so people that did not like
the message regardless of where you
stand on these social issues or gender
narrative or whatever
they took it out by basically boycotting
the product immediately yeah and
switching preference to other brands
that did not make them get involved in
this issue now if you're trying to
manage that and trying to learn
something from it and I certainly talk
to all my CEOs about this because
here we are talking about it in its
second month yeah this is a nightmare
from hell for the brand so when you go
into gender narrative on a beer which is
primarily consumed by men maybe you
should have thought a little bit about
that in reading that room maybe you
should say well does this really fit my
consumer's psyche and
he's got to lay a way of laying it out
pretty cleanly it's interesting because
yes beer tends to be drank more by men
than women for decades and decades it
was marketed directly to men you may
remember the clip that we played last
week where I just so happened to be
watching an old Tonight Show from around
1975 and they've got Ed McMahon doing a
live read in the middle of The Tonight
Show for Budweiser and it's about
watching a game and eating a sandwich
and then Flash Forward 40 some odd years
and they've got Dylan Mulvaney this
trans man whatever potentially with the
Wang I'm not going to have anyone Google
it today uh
you know doing you a solid today
um you can see how these things have
shifted and I would say not in the right
direction but it's interesting also
because what O'Leary is saying is they
might have wanted to think about this
first now I think they did think about
it first we've played you the videos of
that VP of marketing at Anheuser-Busch
who was saying how embarrassed she was
basically by their clientele right she
was saying it was always marketed
towards guys like Frat Boys but that's
not really what we're into and at the
end of the day I'm fairly certain that
if you're hired at a beer company your
job is to sell beer not to socially
engineer the people who are buying the
beer and that is the problem but we've
got some results from this uh it's not
even an official boycott right as far as
I know there's no organization behind it
this is just actually a Grassroots
boycott of Bud Light and it is crushing
them this is from NBC sales of Bud Light
continue to plummet reflecting ongoing
backlash to the Brand's decision to hire
transgen gender influencer Dylan
Mulvaney as a spokesperson according to
data cited by the beverage industry
trade publication beer business daily
sales volumes of Bud Light for the week
ending May 13th sank 28.4 percent
extending a downward trend from the
27.7 decline seen the week before that's
massive that is massive and a little bit
more here because now this is bleeding
into some other companies this is from
the New York Post Target loses 10
billion in 10 days as stocks fall
following boycott over
lgbtq friendly kids clothing I hate I
hate as you know I hate that phrase this
grouping of people
lgbtq I don't even know what Q is I
don't know what two spirit is or any of
that but the t's are rabidly against the
LG's and the bees and people need to
stop combining those things we'll have
more on the target side of things in
just a sec but now I will do CB
Distillery you guys know that after I
tore my ACL I tried every solution there
was out of all the remedies CBD from CB
Distillery was incredibly helpful given
how much pain relief it brought to my
ACL it's not fixed but it doesn't hurt
as much CB Distillery is over 2 million
satisfied customers with 90 percent of
them reporting that they sleep better
with CBD 81 saying they have a reduction
in stress thanks to their CBD and eighty
percent of them saying their aches and
pains are relieved from their CBD after
physical activity so if you struggle
with sleep stress pain or if you're just
frustrated with a health concern that's
not getting better try CBD from the
source side trust CBD
cbdistillery.com let me get you on the
right path with the 20 off discount
visit cbdistillery.com enter my name
Dave for your discount no prescription
required cbdistillery.com promo code
Dave for 20 off and now back to me so
okay Target
which is a store that you go to when you
need a bunch of random crap do you need
a big television do you need a
toothbrush do you need off Market shoes
and do you need a frozen pizza let's go
to Target uh well they're also big on
pushing all of this LGBT pride month
stuff
now as I often say
I'm not against the Elves and the bees
and the G's my husband's one of them
okay I accept these people it's just
fine the problem is that the t's are
attacking those people they're also the
t's are also attacking the women right
because they want biological men to beat
the crap out of women in women's boxing
and a whole bunch more but also they are
marketing this stuff towards children so
I want to be very very clear about this
this is not about how any adult chooses
to live their life they are putting in
children's sections things on how young
boys can tuck do you know what that is
it's fairly unpleasant actually it's
literally so that they can tuck their
genitals so they don't appear to be a
boy this is what they are marketing
towards children so parents have now
seen these uh displays in Target by the
way at our local Target here I don't
know if you guys have been there I did
not see any of this I don't know if
that's a Florida thing or they just
checked out the local marketing or
whatever but I did not see it here I was
at Target over the weekend I had to pick
up prescription which I will switch to
uh to CBS as soon as possible but anywho
um there is some blowback now and
Target's paying the price here is video
from NBC reporting the target is in a
bit of trouble
a controversy over pride month products
is causing headaches for retail giant
Target it says safety is behind its
decision to Halt some sales Miguel
almaguer explains
tonight Target one of the nation's
largest retailers is pulling some
products that celebrate pride month off
store shelves citing threats to
employees the company says given these
volatile circumstances we are making
adjustments to our plans including
removing items that have been at the
center of the most significant
confrontational Behavior okay gizzard
like
naked people on shirts the retailer
removing lgbtq brand at prowlin from
their stores and website whose products
featured satanic themes Target also
reportedly reviewing its adult
collection of Tuck friendly swimsuits
that allows trans people who have not
had gender affirming operations to
conceal their private parts those items
have been at the center of
misinformation
those items have been at the center of
misinformation again this is about kids
this stuff is always pushed in kids
sections also you might be wondering why
they would have said let's put aside the
lgbtq2 spirit stuff for just a sec let's
just say we're all good with that why do
they have they literally had a satanic
trans person as the lead designer all
this they were putting satanic messages
that you could buy they had little uh
Little Gems and things and things on the
shirts satanic messages for the children
is that a problem like what in God's
name is going on here but of course what
they're doing first off NBC calls it
misinformation you know whatever but
what they're also doing is they're
playing the victim oh we're removing
this stuff because people were trying to
be mean to us they were saying mean
things and threatening our employees
there were no threats this is complete
nonsense what they are threatened by is
that their bottom dollar is being hit
right 10 billion dollar loss of your
stock that might be a reason to change
course and that's also the beauty
when people themselves make choices and
you stop funding the organizations that
are working against your values then
they turn around but they don't want to
say that like oh actually maybe this
wasn't the best idea and we shouldn't be
pushing this tucking nonsense on
children oh well it's because those
crazy Ultra Maga people I have no doubt
were actually coming to hurt our
employees just nonsense but if you want
to see how deep this stuff is and this
is what you have to understand because
you might be watching this and I think
the average person watches this stuff
and they're like why is it it doesn't
make sense when I've been to these
stores in other targets and and other
stores like this there's never anyone
buying any of this stuff right there's
never anyone in those sections you never
see anyone wearing any of this stuff so
the question is why is it there and it
has much more to do with how these
organizations are set up the diversity
Equity inclusion groups that are in
their ESG and more than whether they
have a desire to make a profit and that
is a problem this is video of Target CEO
Brian Cornell explaining that it is his
mission now I thought the mission of a
Target CEO would be to sell as much crap
as possible so the Target stock price
goes up so the shareholders are happy
you've put out a product you make some
money
you go home but no his mission is to
advance diversity equity and inclusion
some of the companies that I've worked
with whether it's Target today or in the
past working for PepsiCo you know that
Common Thread was recognizing that
diverse and inclusive environments
delivered great results yeah and I've
always tried to ensure that our
leadership team our organization
reflected the consumer we serve and when
you get that equation right it's the
right thing for society it's the right
thing for the team it's also the right
thing for business and shareholders so I
think we all have an oversized role to
play right now to advance diversity and
inclusion
to stand next to our black leaders who
need our support to make sure it's
really clear in our industry and our
companies
we're not going to tolerate racism and
to work to make the right changes both
internally and then working
as a collective group to make changes in
our communities and in our country that
are going to have a lasting effect
guys he's not going to tolerate racism
by hiring people based on race he's
going to literally look at skin color
and gender and sexuality and hire people
in exact accordance with their
demographic oh God it's so terrible note
he didn't step down I would imagine that
there's a black guy out there who's
capable of being the Target CEO and yet
you've got this rich white guy Mr
Cornell okay Cornell's got some cash but
Cornell is going to defeat racism by
hiring ex-black lesbians and why trans
this and that and the other thing again
you know people goes in I had him on the
show years ago when he was talking about
this that once you let I don't even know
that people were really fully calling it
diversity equity and inclusion yet but
once you let this woke mind virus into
the system whatever system it's in it
will destroy the system because then you
have people like CEOs of companies again
who whose only job his job is to grow
Target to sell product to make as many
people want to buy the most amount of
goods possible there right and then
that's the beauty of capitalism because
another big box store could open and
then they could go oh there's Best Buy
is selling TVs cheaper than we are we
better lower our prices then competition
happens we get more development like
that's the beauty of the of the whole
thing but then when you have this woke
mind virus in there and you're caring
more about how many black lesbian uh
greeters you have at the store uh you've
got a problem because you are now not
doing what your main mission is as a CEO
of a company and you might go well why
is it that this white man this Brian
Cornell he never seemingly did anything
about this in the rest of his career
suddenly really really cares about this
sort of stuff well here's Target's Chief
diversity and inclusion officer her name
is Kiera Fernandez uh and she's uh
pushing the white women to to get on
board because if you're not on board
Whitey you're against us
what would you say is the number one
thing white women could do as we talk
about helping more bipoc women rise into
leadership what's the one thing that
white women could do to be helpful
Kira do you want to start
I'd love to I I think the number one
thing that
I would encourage white women to do is
take the learnings that you're that
you've invested uh to better understand
and use your voice
yeah white woman you better do what I
say do you see how this is a hostage
situation I don't know who that white
woman is that she was talking to over
there but white woman in your little box
up there you must step down why can't
you be replaced by a black lesbo come on
woman what are you doing and what the
hell's a woman
people are all completely ridiculous but
it continues Miss Fernandez here tells
all of the employees at Target they
better accept diversity Equity inclusion
Dei although it should really be called
diversity inclusion and Equity die
because that's really what they want for
the white people that if they don't get
on board this woke lunatic program they
can find another place to work
it is import ant for us to also
acknowledge that not everyone is going
to believe or be bought into are
strategies and our priorities on this
topic
they just aren't and so um when we talk
about leader accountability and the
importance of representation and these
strategies and these goals being
integrated into someone's responsibility
um like just to be really pragmatic and
practical
then it becomes okay you don't Nest like
we may not be able to change your mind
shift on appreciating why this is
important but you do understand that as
a part of your job responsibilities you
will lead inclusively you will have
representation on your team you will be
responsible for these behaviors values
and expectations and it also quite
frankly puts a lot on the folks that
don't believe in this but emphasizes
that you still have to do it to do this
job to be a part of this company
and eventually
um you'll see a change in their mindset
or they may leave and you know that's a
part of this process too this isn't for
everyone
you guys see how evil this is if you do
not get on board they're neo-racist idea
set they are saying to you don't work
here we will push you out eventually you
know I realized as we were watching that
when I do this show every day I'm
looking at four white people
okay I got four white people in front of
me two on this side of me and two on
this side and I have to say frankly it's
disgusting and I want one of you to show
up in blackface tomorrow okay it's the
only what oh
Connor pointed that way he'll do it
he'll do it sorry Phoenix you're gonna
have to show up in blackface to her I
can't look at these white people I'm
trying to do a show here and I see no
diversity Equity inclusion I just see
whiteness
The Psychotic lunacy related to all of
this it's never going to stop and you
also must understand that the
corporations not just the corporations
like Bud Light and and Target the ones
that are selling you crap and by the way
then you can find if you want beer you
can find other places to get beer which
is exactly what Kevin O'Leary said right
like just go go ahead and do that and by
the other people will capitalize and
that's that's great Target I'm telling
you right now I'm not going to Target
anymore I have gone to Target I bought
an air fryer at Target last month I was
at Target this weekend because that's
where our it's the closest pharmacy to
us so I had to pick up something for
Luke I'm done I'm not going to shop
there anymore we have to stop doing this
right I got rid of Disney plus you can
do something in your life and I think
hopefully you will do something in your
life and I wonder you know also
at Target like they they have Magnolia
products you know chip and Joanna Gaines
I like those chip that chip and Joanna
you know them right like are they happy
about this like maybe they should move
their stuff somewhere else like everyone
has a little bit of a role to play in
all this but it's not just the
corporations that are selling you the
stuff like the beer companies and Target
it's also that the corporate structure
when it comes to Media is also designed
to confuse and lie to you about
absolutely everything
so here's some MSNBC contributor I've
never seen this guy before his name's
Justin wolford's saying that if you go
after Target you're a terrorist
when Target caves into this then it says
that the moment you threaten the
employees of even a very large
corporation you get to control its
policies this is economic terrorism
literally terrorism creating fear among
the workers enforcing the corporations
to sell the things you want not sell the
things you don't it's economic terrorism
if you don't shop at a place that's
against your values it's terrorism guess
what guys we found he's right though
joking aside I want to stop the joking
I've been a little jokey today we did
find some video of the horrific
terrorism that the ultramaga right-wing
Maniacs have been doing at Target check
this video out this is this is just wild
[Music]
ah you saw what I did there no that was
an Ultra Mega white supremacists who
were pissed about talking that was BLM
and antifa because they burned down
Target and Fatboy in the name of
Tolerance and diversity so who else is
the media calling terrorists well you
know it's where I live the people of the
Free State of Florida we'll get to that
in just a second let me talked about
Phoenix Capital you know with banks
collapsing in the turbulent state of the
stock market millions of Americans have
watched their retirement savings
disappear I want to share with you a
unique investment opportunity that's not
only protecting retirement savings but
investors are seeing consistent yields
and growth Phoenix Capital group is
offering high-value U.S oil and gas
Investments through their corporate
bonds it's a way for people to invest in
energy assets and diversify their
portfolio yields range from 8 to 12
percent apy paid monthly with different
qualifications and maturity dates
Phoenix Capital group is a tech-led
Energy company owning in some of the
most lucrative basins Across America
investor Capital along with their own
Capital goes towards cash flow positive
oil and gas projects they had the choice
of offering a significantly lower
interest rate and paying the difference
to middlemen but decided to break the
mold and bring stronger Investments
directly to investors these eight to
twelve percent apy corporate bonds are
higher than CDs or annuities often more
than double the typical yields so if
you're looking for an alternative
investment with sizable yields and
monthly payment options I highly
recommend checking out Phoenix Capital
groups Bond offerings to learn more
download their free investor guide today
at
phxonrubin.com let them know you heard
it from me alright so who else is a
terrorist well you know it's got to be
the free state of Florida check out this
tweet I saw over the weekend from CNN
Florida boasts hundreds of miles of
beaches year-round warm temperatures and
is home to the world's most famous theme
park but political battles that have
been heating up in recent months could
cast a shadow over the sunshine State's
tourism appeal uh now it's funny that
they put this out there because it could
except it didn't because Florida just
closed its biggest yes largest quarter
of Tourism ever despite our anti-gazed
stance and our anti-black stance and
desantises mean more people than ever
are not only moving here but vacationing
here this is another gem this one here
we go Rolling Stone a furry fandom Con
in Florida just announced it would ban
miners based on the governor's
ridiculous laws Connor leave this up for
just a moment because we have to unpack
what's going on here so first off you
are watching the Reuben report you're
good family people you don't know what a
furry fandom kind is Brock what's a
furry fandom con
we should go we we should go it is look
there's a certain set of people who who
am I to judge they dress up as these
furry animals I don't know they hang out
they have coffee I guess they maybe have
sex or whatever they're doing with each
other that's fine they've canceled their
convention by the way nobody had a
problem with their convention I think
better O'Rourke is one of these people
nobody had a problem with these people
that dress up as plush animals and hang
out with other people dressed as plush
animals and you do it in the privacy of
your own home or in a convention
somewhere but you don't do it in front
of children because joking aside there
actually is a sexual element to it okay
that they have sex as oh you're you're a
Charmander and I'm
something else
can you imagine how stupid everything's
gonna be in 10 years I have to retire
that's it I'm getting out of the grind
who needs it
um but all Florida did was say you can't
bring children to your furry sex party
so now put it up again because the way
Rolling Stone frames it it makes it seem
like Florida's doing the wrong thing a
furry fandom Con in Florida just
announced it would ban miners based on
the governor's ridiculous laws all the
governor said was don't bring kids when
you put on a dragon costume and bang
some dude from out of state
speaking of which we played this clip
last week and I had a feeling it was
going to come back but this is a woman
named Aisha Mills She's a Lesbian she's
some sort of lesbian it's very exciting
for her she uh thinks that Florida is a
terrorist State and I just love this
clip and it sort of packages everything
we're doing here
you know I just took my family to spring
break in Florida recently and I think
about all of the folks who traveled
there for Sun and joy and peace and
restoration and to be reminded that
actually this is getting to the point
where Florida is about to be a terrorist
state to many of us here in America
certainly as a lesbian as a black woman
I don't want to have anything to do with
the plate this black lesbian doesn't
want anything to do with the place even
though she just took her family here and
nothing happened to them they obviously
were just fine Florida's absolutely fan
freaking tastic but it's on the verge of
becoming a terrorist State you know if
it was right there let's say it really
was on the precipice of becoming a
terrorist state it was just teetering
little terrorism over here it was just
teetering would you be like you know
what two weeks before let's go to
vacation there come on wifey let's go
take the kids oh and they also hate
black people it's a black thing it's a
lesbo thing
it's endless it is endless and they will
never stop so why do they hate Florida
you know why because they fear Florida
that is the truth they fear freedom
because our governor here and it's by
extension our people here are the ones
who are crushing the woke virus we are
crushing it in our corporations in our
institution and most importantly in our
culture here in Florida nobody wants
anything to do with this and we're
showing people that it can be crushed
that is a beautiful thing so let's
continue with the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC there is this
guy David Jolly he once was a republican
Congressman uh here in Florida he is now
a Democrat activist but they put
Republican under his name so it looks
good for MSNBC like if you if you ever
read an article in mainstream media New
York Times CNN wapo Etc where they're
grabbing a republican to talk about
DeSantis and it's just filled with lies
and and crap it's this guy David Jolly
he's just an absolute embarrassment you
don't need to know him he's irrelevant
but they put him on MSNBC and here he is
fear-mongering about Ron DeSantis
because what did I tell you guys months
ago they are going to make it that Ron
DeSantis is scarier than Trump trump was
Hitler but DeSantis is Hitler with the
calculator so watch out take a look at
this
David last word to you you and I have
talked a great deal about defenses
authoritarianism in Florida nevertheless
were you shocked by his announcement
this week that he would quote
aggressively go after pardons for one
six insurrectionists
no media I say this with conviction I
think Rhonda Sanchez is far more
dangerous than Donald Trump for a very
specific reason Donald Trump is willing
to ignore the rules ignore the
Constitution and frankly lead to the
incitement of January 6 but Donald Trump
is a transactional figure he'll do
whatever it takes to win Ron DeSantis I
believe actually in his ethos is a
culture Warrior who wants to take us
back a hundred years and believes he can
use the Constitution to that to that end
and ultimately has a very dark vision of
what America will be so the idea of
pardoning January 6 uh convicts if you
will at this point is because he
believes we are engaged in a real war
that he has to win London Sanchez
tonight a very dark figure on the
political landscape far more dangerous
than Donald Trump let me be clear David
we in we are in a war and we are going
to win it because people like you do not
deserve to win it and you're
anti-American sort of psychotic like at
least he's not screaming you know
usually on MSNBC there's a certain set
of Hysteria I appreciate the fact that
the guy calmly sits there okay now he
should be replaced by a black woman I
don't know why they're bringing on a
white political person on MSNBC there's
so many qualified black lesbians uh some
of them in wheelchairs that should be on
that program instead of him but that's
for the MSNBC people to figure out when
they're adding up how many white
correspondents they have and all that
um the idea that DeSantis is the vision
for the country is dark he wants to take
us back 100 years yeah he doesn't want
black people to vote he doesn't want
women to vote like
F off you people are just pathetic
Ridiculousness what they really fear is
that finally finally guys we have a
politician who gets it who is competent
who is clear who's taken the hits and
moving forward and accomplishing
everything he set out to do but don't
take my word for it uh here's Ron
DeSantis talking about how Trump is now
attacking him from the left which of
course is exactly what MSNBC is doing
but the idea that MSNBC and Trump are on
the same side is sort of interesting
wouldn't you say
well I think it's interesting because
he's been attacking me by moving left so
this is a different guy than 2015 2016.
he attacked me for opposing an amnesty
bill in the Congress he did support this
amnesty this good lap too two million
illegal aliens he wanted to amnesty I
opposed it because that's what America
First principles dictate that you're
opposed to amnesty he also attacked me
for voting against an Omnibus spending
bill that was bloated full of pork and
that racked up huge amount of debt for
this country yes I voted against the
Omnibus he signed every Omnibus that was
put on his desk and so I think it's odd
that he's doubling down on those
positions because those were instances
in which his actions did not match his
campaign rhetoric yeah those are facts
those are facts and we're going to get
to Trump in just a second on his
specific words on that but DeSantis did
not want amnesty for 2 million people
right if you're for America First would
you have have amnesty for two million
people who inherently by being here
broke the law or would you say build a
wall perhaps figure out what that
pathway to citizenship is get rid of a
certain amount of people who are here
illegally figure out an entire process
but Trump Not only was he not getting
the wall he got certain parts of it done
obviously but he did want amnesty Trump
uh DeSantis himself did not vote for it
here's Trump saying he's for the amnesty
for the two million people
and I'm going to be over the next few
weeks signing an immigration bill that a
lot of people don't know about it you
have breaking news but I'm signing a big
immigration bill this is an executive
order I'm going to do a big executive
order I have the power to do it as
president and I'm going to make DACA a
part of it but we put it in and we're
probably going to then be taking it out
we're working out the legal complexities
right now but I'm going to be signing a
very major immigration bill as an
executive order
which Supreme Court now because of the
DACA decision has given me the power to
do that one of the aspects of the bill
is going to be DACA we're going to have
a road to citizenship okay so that's as
an executive order not as a
congressional if you look at the Supreme
Court ruling they gave the president
tremendous Powers when they said that
you could take in in this case 700 000
or so people so they gave Powers based
on the powers that they gave I'm going
to be doing an immigration Bill one of
the aspects of the bill that you'll be
very happy with and that a lot of people
will be including me and a lot of
Republicans by the way will be DACA
we'll give them a road to citizenship
okay so I'm not actually showing you
that video which of course was from 2018
when Trump was President I'm not showing
that to attack Trump the Democrats
deserve way more of our criticism during
the Trump years than Trump does when it
came to making any deal because Trump
would make a deal the Democrats went out
of their way it's on record now where
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi you were
saying we would not make a deal with him
no matter what because they didn't want
to give him any sort of win but when
Trump's talking about 700 000 people
there it was really two million people
that they were going to give amnesty to
that's what the scientists voted against
you know the other interesting thing
over the last couple days we're not even
covering it today but I'm sure some
Fallout of it will come over the next
few days is this debt ceiling deal where
it looks like McCarthy's about to cave
and what have I been saying for a long
time it's like Republicans it seemed
like they were getting some balls
McCarthy's trying to spin it as a win
but it's it's not really a win and this
is where Trump comes to odds with his
own base because Trump backed McCarthy
now I happen to like Evan McCarthy and
we we'll see if they maybe get some more
leverage out of it but the guys that I
really like in the Senate and the
Congress guys like Rand Paul Ted Cruz
chip Roy Thomas Massey the fiscal
conservatives the guys that are fighting
the hardest to get us out of War really
drain the swamp they're all against the
deal but Trump backed McCarthy these are
just realities that the Trump base is
going to have to come to that he was for
amnesty he is for the guy who's going to
raise the debt ceiling again so there's
just like a lot of information coming
from all sorts of directions that people
really have to think through uh here's a
little bit more uh on from DeSantis on
Trump when it comes to Disney
specifically because Trump has has sort
of defended Disney against DeSantis
because none of his attacks on DeSantis
are working so he's just throwing crap
all over the place so here's DeSantis on
that
Trump I think a lot of conservatives you
know we kind of laugh when you hear it
but a lot of conservatives believe that
a trump the Santa's or DeSantis Trump
ticket is unbeatable real quick thought
on that and then we'll go into some some
of the other stuff
yeah you know I don't know I mean I
think that some of the things he's been
attacking me on I've been a little
surprised at because he's attacking me
from the left and that really wasn't the
Donald Trump from 2015 and 2016 I mean
he was a hard charger leaning in on all
the issues very edgy on conservative
issues and it was part of the reason he
did so well uh but when he's taken
Disney side against me I just kind of
Wonder like okay I get he wants to hit
me but don't take the side of a
multinational corporation that wants to
sexualized kids but to hit me for being
taken the America first position I just
think is a little little strange so I'm
not sure what his strategy is but I
think he's taking positions that are a
little bit different than uh than four
or five years ago okay so you might be
watching this going wait what do you
mean how is how is Trump taking the side
of Disney he's been attacking DeSantis
left and right but how's he taking the
side of Disney we'll get to that in just
a second but I saw this video this
morning this is like the first thing
when I opened up Twitter you know I try
not to tweet over the weekends open up
Twitter this morning this is like the
first thing I saw it's going viral right
now this is a video that some somebody
took at Disneyland over the weekend this
is the girl this is where the girls go
this I mean it's so nuts this is the
store at Disneyland where the girls go
to buy dresses so they can dress up like
princesses while they're at Disneyland
tell me if you think something's a
little odd here
[Music]
I wonder if I got another apprentices
I'm here to shop you around
McDonald's for the day
okay
you must understand first off this is
not a trans person that's a man in a
dress hence he still has a Mustang right
so that's a transvestite not a
transsexual that's not someone as far as
I can tell who's identifying as a woman
you wouldn't keep the must there so why
would you intentionally confuse these
children again that dude who is a dude
can do whatever he wants in the privacy
of his own life he could actually have
any job at Disneyland he could be in a
full costume he could be selling hot
dogs he could be a guy that's in charge
of the lines at the rides all of those
things but Disney made a choice oh at
the outside of the store where a bunch
of 5 to 12 year old girls are going to
walk in to get in dresses we will have a
man with a mustache wearing a dress is
that why anyone goes to Disney to have
their children confused again this has
nothing to do with bigotry or racism or
any anything else like that but that is
exactly why Disney must be hit they made
an intentional choice to do that so
imagine you're the average guy
the average family man who has two kids
you have let's say you have a son and a
daughter you take them there to Disney
as you know if you were trying to go to
the Star Wars thing for a family of four
it was like five thousand bucks a night
so they just closed that or actually
they announce it'll be closing it closes
actually in October but it's a
tremendous failure just on the financial
level but then you go to Disney and your
daughter loves Little Mermaid and you
want to get her in a dress and now she's
six-year-old and then a guy with a
mustache is like come in come in and put
on a dress and now like it's just it's
just entered your daughter's mind this
confusion and that's what they want
everybody to be they want everybody to
be confused so let's continue a little
bit on how it is that Trump because he
wants to do anything to damage DeSantis
and DeSantis is the one hitting Disney
which deserves to be hit how Trump
actually is now basically taking this
side of Disney he's shifting his tone on
Disney this is a tweet from Pedro
Gonzalez Pedro is a great actual
journalist I had him on the show about a
week ago on the panel show he said a
poll Trump shared last month that showed
him leading DeSantis has flipped the
same firm has now DeSantis ahead of
trump post announcement that explains
Trump's ridiculous truth social post
about Disney today siding with Disney
against DeSantis cost him support so
we'll get to that truth social Post in
just a minute they said one Trump just
out I guess Ron DeSantis is not quite as
popular in Florida as people thought I
assume among other things that they
don't want their social security and
Medicare cut and what he's showing you
here is an interactive polls uh poll
survey a Florida Republican primary that
had trumpet 47 and DeSantis at 32. now
the second tweet here
Floridians choose Trump this is from the
Maga war room and they're showing 47
Trump and 32 percent DeSantis this is
back in April now you'll see where where
Pedro is going with this uh three
interactive polls 2024 Florida primary
DeSantis now this is May 25th to 27th so
this is the last couple days now
DeSantis is now at 38 which is plus
three Trump is at 38 which is -5 Haley
someone else undecided fine and in a
two-way match-up uh DeSantis is now in
the lead 40 Trump 39 undecided 21 look I
don't like getting lost before we get to
the the other post I don't like getting
lost in all these numbers right I say
that all the time but there clearly is a
shift you don't relentlessly all day
attack the number two guy especially
when he's a guy you endorsed especially
when he's a guy who is the governor of
the state that you and all of your
family members live in right also is
Trump even campaigning like he's playing
golf relentlessly like is he even out
there who's working for his campaign
like something I'm telling you something
weird is going on here whether you like
it or not there is something there is a
shift and something weird is going on
here but here's the specific uh truth
social posts that Trump put
uh about Disney he said Disney has
become awoke and disgusting shadow of
its former self with people actually
hating it must go back to what it once
was or the market will do irreparable
damage this all all happened during the
governorship of Rob de sanctimonious
instead of complaining now for publicity
reasons only he should have stopped it
long ago would have been easy to do
still is I mean that is such abject
meaningless drivel
like I don't even know how to analyze
that properly first off Rob how is
calling him Rob offensive Rob is a name
Ron is the name like it's just nothing
like you've just got nothing you are an
idiot and I'm sorry to say it but you
are at this point uh so okay and then to
sanctimonious it's just meaning nothing
like you are the most sanctimonious
person ever but okay fine what is he
saying
DeSantis should have done something
about Disney years ago
well he's doing something now you never
did anything like what are you saying
Trump if you're watching this if you're
if you're uh let me say something about
Trump you know over the weekend
um I'll tweet about this also because I
think it's important for for people to
know for people that maybe didn't watch
the full episode today or whatever over
the weekend uh I I texted Don Jr Don Jr
and I were friends before his dad was a
politician and my and we're friends now
and my my intention is that we'll be
friends long after this thing now
obviously we're on different sides of
things but I texted him over the weekend
and I said hey Don I've been meaning to
reach out to you and I just want you to
know that even if we're on a different
side of things now I put friendship
above politics and I'll never say
anything bad about the family I actually
go out of my way to say that you've been
a good friend and Ivanka and blah blah
blah blah he immediately within like
three seconds wrote back saying almost
the exact same thing right back to me so
maybe we'll do it publicly and have a
debate about it that I didn't even
Broach that topic but the point is
there's a way to not lose your your mind
completely in all of this and I intend
to do that to the best of my ability but
when Trump posts these Rob Des
sanctimonious I hate Disney you should
have done like it's just
it's just nuts so why is the whole
machine attacking Florida the NAACP the
LGBT groups everyone's attacking Florida
these clowns on MSNBC it's because
DeSantis is the guy that can crush this
thing and everyone knows it and what
he's also going to do in the process of
it is he's going to make it so that
Republicans actually to quote Joe Biden
will get a backbone like a ramrod
and this the idea of the establishment
Republican will be will be a thing of
the past but that's what they're trying
to put on DeSantis right now and he's
just not having it
well I can tell you this here I have not
spoken to Paul Ryan since I've been
Governor I've met Karl Rove once in my
life they are not involved in my
political operation so that's just
manufactured garbage that people put out
there online so people are telling you
that you know I'd hope that they'll uh
they'll look at the facts rather than do
that you also look at my record how many
establishment Republicans would have
sent illegal aliens to Martha's Vineyard
how many establishment Republicans would
have stood up against Disney how many
establishment Republicans would have
signed the bill that I just signed to
ban land purchases from people
affiliated with the CCP in the State of
Florida we're now being sued by the ACLU
for that how many establishment
Republicans would have leaned in to
support our children against the pronoun
Olympics we banned the pronoun Olympics
in our schools were the first state to
do that how many establishment
Republicans would have banned gender
transition surgeries for minors we not
only would take the doctor's medical
license we'll put the doctor in jail ill
if they are mutilating minor so on every
issue that kind of the old guard of the
Republican Party would have shied away
from in a New York minute I'm not only
leaning into them I'm winning against
the media and against the left you know
we say Florida is the place where woke
goes to die because we've defeated the
left on all these fronts and my pledge
if I'm elected president after two terms
we will leave woke ideology in the
Dustbin of History
clean and clear and honest it's as
simple as that but I want to address
what he said up top at that not all of
the dominoes you guys get the dominoes
all the good things that he's done and
that he has just set out to do these
things and he knocks them down one at a
time and watches the rest fall okay fine
everyone gets that I want to get I want
to talk about that Paul Ryan and Karl
Rove thing so because Trump and this is
this is where Trump with the lying it's
too much he Trump has a run around
screaming on Truth social that that Ron
DeSantis is somehow in bed with Paul
Ryan and Karl Rove now first off
DeSantis just said it right there so if
it's a lie it'll come out but I don't
think it's a lie that he has not spoken
to Paul Ryan since he has been Governor
that was in 2018 that's when he became
Governor we're now into 2023 five years
later so Paul Ryan ain't part of this
operation he then said he spoke he has
spoken to Karl roof once in his life
okay so it is a complete fabrication
that somehow that somehow DeSantis is in
bed with Paul Ryan Paul Ryan by the way
who we've played you the clips before
and we can do it again there there are
like endless probably a hundred clips of
Donald Trump praising Paul Ryan okay so
it's like come on dude enough enough
with this stuff and praising Carl enough
with this absolute nonsense or the idea
that they have anything to do with the
campaign and I see this I see this with
the Trump Twitter people all day long
well ASE Trump said to Santos is in bed
with Paul Ryan and Jeb Bush and it's
like guys he's doing everything you want
that was the rest of the clip right
here's what I've done this is what they
all would have shied away from so the
point is that he's the only Republican
that has not only destroyed the woke on
a policy front he's done it on the
cultural front as well because if you're
happy that Bud Light is paying the price
it's because he was
showing people there's a way to fight if
you're happy that people are pushing
against Target it's because he's showing
it if you're happy that people are not
pleased when they try to buy a dress for
their daughter and there's a dude in a
dress welcoming them into the store it's
because he showed it and guess what
there's evidence that when you do the
right thing that you'll win elections
and I suspect that's what's going to
happen here you know this already but
from the Washington Post 2018 what
happened well DeSantis barely beat uh
Andrew Gillum it was 49.6 percent uh
which is what he got versus 49.2 for
Gillum that was 32 000 votes it turned
out that Andrew Gillum was a gay black
meth addict and they say gay people
aren't welcome in Florida come on
um I think technically he says he's
bisexual now or something but okay and
then of course what happened last time
well the Santa's crushed it 59.4 percent
of the vote over 1.5 million votes so
there is a model there is a way there is
a blueprint I think the culture can
shift I think everything can shift in
our Direction and we just got to keep
doing the right thing I think you agree
with me and that's why you tune into
this fine program tomorrow Phoenix will
be here in blackface we've got a post
game show coming up in about 32 seconds
reubenport.locals.com quick cold close
for you and everybody else will see you
tomorrow
that is absolutely cute yes
[Music]